scientists advising the world health
organization say the astrazeneca vaccine
should be given to all adults over 18
with no
upper age limit the recommendation comes
after a number of countries opted not to
give the jab to those
over the age of 65 because of doubts
over its effectiveness
and south africa suspended its rollout
the who's chair of the strategic
advisory group of
experts on immunization dr alejandro
craviotto
had this to say since we have identified
people over 65 was one of our priority
groups
in the prioritization roadmap we
have based a totality of
looking at the safety and the
immunogenicity data
and therefore we recommend for the
vaccine to be used
in people 18 years and above without an
upper age limit that means people over
65 years of age
should be given the vaccination well
let's bring in our science correspondent
thomas moore now put this into context
for us why has the world health
organization had to issue this guidance
thomas
well i think all countries were looking
to the world health organization to do
just that because
the vaccine is now available and they
wanted the best available
recommendations for its use and i think
what they have
essentially decided is that yes there
are gaps
in the data there is a limit to the
copper bottoms evidence that comes from
clinical trials but
filling in the gaps they do believe that
the vaccine is effective in
the older patients and that it should be
given between
eight and uh with a a dose interval of
eight to twelve weeks as it is being
given here in the uk
and then it should be given even though
uh there may be variants that may reduce
its effectiveness now on all three
points let's go back to the first one
the elderly of course uh president
macron of france he has said that
the vaccine was quasi-ineffective the
german vaccine
advisers uh said that it shouldn't be
used in the elderly until there's
stronger evidence
but the double eho has very much sided
with the uk
and how it's being used here and after
days
of of uh really quite uh uh
strong uh criticism of the way the
vaccine is being used that perhaps
undermine public confidence this is a
a strong vote of confidence for the
astrazeneca oxford vaccine